you got your victory dance well i got it
right here
yeah your high five and walking out to
the jet and stuff like that
you're most likely going to die on that
mission hey gq
it's wiz welcome back to part two of the
breakdown where we're going to be
watching some more
awesome fighter pilot clips
[Music]
first up independence first wave in our
day
our target is to the north centered
above
what remains of downtown los angeles
got to stop right here love independence
day
because now the marine corps gets a
little love here we know marine corps
aviators are in fact naval aviators
and even coast guard so navy marine and
coast guard aviators we all wear the uh
the same
wings of gold as a naval aviator so
who's given the brief right now
it's it's a little awkward to usually if
the person leading the flight the flight
lead will give the brief
at this point it looks like some high
rank in general or something like that
is given the brief so up until the
flight lead steps up there
you might have an intelligence person
come up and give their part of the brief
the weather person absolutely has to
come up and give her breathe maybe the
the general or the admiral steps up to
give a little newt rockne speech but the
flight lead
whoever's leading this thing airborne
that's the person that's going to lead
the brief ultimately
bring that bad boy you lose your side
got your victory dance well i got it
right here
so how we're feeling at this moment
walking out to the aircraft depends on
the type of mission we're going to be
flying and no matter what whether it was
wartime
or a peace mission when you're walking
up onto the flight deck of an aircraft
carrier everything changes
you put your game face on one of the
most dangerous places on the face of the
earth
to walk or to work is the flight deck of
an aircraft carrier you got propellers
spinning you got jet blast you got
people getting blown overboard you get
people walking
in the propellers accidentally so
walking around on the flight line you
want to get in your jet as quick as
possible
but walking out to the aircraft
especially if it is a combat mission
you kind of got your game face on for
taught to compartmentalize
meaning i'm not wondering you know if i
paid the mortgage
is the grass too long or anything like
that you have to
put all those things aside to focus on
the mission at the end of the day
we are all about the mission and we are
focused if you're high five and walking
out to the jet and stuff like that
you're most likely going to die on that
mission hey you don't get pre-patrol on
me soldier we don't light up to the fat
ladies
when i heard that line i could hear
every marine
across the world literally their head
explode he called him soldier
don't ever call a united states marine
a soldier a soldier is in the united
states army
a marine is in the united states marines
it's a huge misperception about fighter
pilots
especially in these movies captain jimmy
whatever it says wild
raven a lot of people think that that's
your jet
that's not your jet so in a typical
fighter squadron we might have anywhere
from 12 to 15
jets the first two jets in the squadron
they have the name of the commander of
the air group and then the commanding
officers jet
and then the executive officer and then
it kind of goes down the picking order
until
we're running out of pilots or running
out of jets so a common
misconception about fighter aircraft is
that
that's your airplane so the pre-flight
preparation that you're seeing
in independence day is pretty realistic
walking up to the aircraft you'll be
greeted by
who is called the plane captain in the
air force it's called the crew chief
they are assigned an airplane and they
know the hydraulics the fuel
they give it the tender love and care
that we just can as aviators so you
salute the plane captain give them a
firm handshake and they're going to give
you a brief about the status of the
aircraft
any what we call gripes hey sir the last
time this jet flew
that the radar had a couple issues or
there were some hydraulic problems so
they'll give you a quick brief
and then you walk around the aircraft
and do a pre-flight because it's an
extra set of eyes
it's what we call mutual support we take
care of each other
all right boys where are they he's here
to target
four minutes
that looks like the battle of britain on
whatever that was supposed to be some
sort of radar screen just a horde
of the good guys going after a bad guy
we wouldn't have that many
aircraft necessarily going that close
but i don't remember reading a book
about
huge ginormous enemy spaceship and the
requirements for the aircraft
but today we have what we call the f-35
the joint strike fighter
it can fly completely autonomously an
f-35 most likely is going into enemy
combat by itself
because it doesn't need anybody else it
has that much
situational awareness so the days of you
know kind of this battle of britain hey
launch everybody type of thing
are kind of going away in essence
why we on this particular mission we'll
never know
but i do know here today that the black
knights
will emerge victorious so the
relationship with your squadron mates
is absolutely uh critical to mission
success
so in a fighter squadron you had to have
absolute trust
faith and confidence in your in your
fellow wingmen
and if you didn't the unit broke down
it's a family
you know there's give and take and
arguments and stuff like that but at the
end of the day
if there's any problems we circle the
wagon and protect each other
we can make fun of each other but if
anybody outside of our squadron did
now you got an ass kicking coming the
willingness to literally lay your life
down
to potentially lose your life to take
care of a squadron mate
really makes it an organization i've
never
seen again in my life i left being a
fighter pilot to go to wall street
and i can't even tell you what a letdown
it was i mean on wall street
the guys will push their own mother in
front of a train to make a buck in the
military just
not it is a complete culture disconnect
they were family members and and are to
this day
next up iron eagle this has got to be
the worst series of
fighter pilot movies god ever created
and it couldn't happen to a better
service the united states air force
it's just you couldn't it couldn't be
any worse
i mean so the navy marine corps team got
top gun
and my air force buddies got iron
yeah if you come up here and show me
where the throttle is
to begin with so we got a teenage kid
flying an f-16
so here's what's funny about all this
stuff so the air force is pretty anal
about a lot of stuff
especially security not that the marine
corps navy
are relaxed about this but we have
bigger things to do like fly
jets off of a boat or storm beaches so
their
security on an air force base is epic
so the fact that this kid like god is
even sitting here right now
is physically impossible i can't even
it gives me agita watching this but
apparently this
this kid's dad was is a air force
fighter pilot or got shot down and
uh you know he's got to rescue him if
the air force is resorting to teenage
kids to rescue their downed pilots
we're in a load of trouble man
this is falcon 6 ready for takeoff okay
for takeoff
[Music]
so the oxygen mask contains your
microphone to talk and obviously oxygen
i hated the thing a minimum you have to
wear during takeoff
and landing what happens if they're
flying along at 400 miles an hour
and something bad happens and they have
to eject there's no wind
and all of a sudden instantaneously
you're in 400 mile an hour wind
that mask is going to rip off probably
take the helmet off and might take your
head off with it too up at higher
altitude
you definitely have to have your mask on
because even
though the cockpit of a fighter jet is
pressurized guess what
you got a little pinhole leak in the
canopy and the pressurization leaks
you could end up dead where you want to
go
you're driving let's see what you got
you sure you're up to it
[Music]
oh man here we go with the with the
music
in the in the in the jet you know
bringing your
what is that a walkman first of all we
have designated operating areas
so as soon as you get all airborne
you're supposed to go be going to a
place
a restricted area a warning area or a
military operations area this whole
hey we just got airborne out of an air
force base let's just start
doing it's comical but let's see what he
does
you know now i'm really starting not to
like you
[Music]
head over to the range so the idea that
this
colonel with thousands of hours in the
f-16
could be like feeling a little not
up to being pulled around by a teenager
is comical at this point it is this is
just pure comedy gold
anytime i took off in the f-18 hornet
even if it was a furry flight for
example taking off out of point a just
to get to point b
i rolled the jet inverted at some point
just getting airborne out of
air force base x to go do some
aerobatics
it doesn't happen i cut off that stuff
let's screw up my rhythm
so we got a teenager in an air force
f-16
dropping live weapons it just doesn't
get any more realistic than this
come on and he needs his music to be
able to bomb correctly
unless it's wired into your headset
you're not going to hear it all we hear
in the jet it's surprisingly quiet
you don't hear the jet engine you hear
the hum
it's the hum of the electronics too and
the and the ecs we call it the
environmental control system there are
guys
nowadays that i know who you know
they'll put their earpods in or
something like that but not
during medicine critical parts
there are limited ranges in the united
states where you can drop
live ordnance but it's it's very very
obviously restricted
away from the civilian population but
you have to drop
live weapons to get familiar with their
use the first time
loading live weapons or you dropping
live weapons in a combat
situation isn't the first time you want
to be doing it
you want to have done this in training a
lot before before doing it live
all right turn this thing on let's let's
head back to base
dammit chappie i'm doing it my way
if if the instructor pilot says all
right this flight's done let's go home
and the guy's like no screw it i'm gonna
do it my way
literally when you got on the deck it
would be it would have been an ass
kicking this is physically impossible
that would have happened it makes me
laugh but
it's just it's inconceivable that this
would happen
well it's better too because he turned
up the volume so he's going to get
better now
because his cheesy 80 music is louder
so yeah you know he just put the bombs
right through the target right there and
he's going to go save his dad
god bless him i would have done the same
thing for my dad
but it never ever would have happened i
love the little
display in the cockpit that said target
destroyed i don't know how the jet
figures out that you destroyed the
target but
yeah that that doesn't happen either so
that's another unrealistic element is
the fact that
i could be sitting in the jet watch the
bomb go right into somebody's window
blow up the entire building
and still not know until we have what we
call bda
battle damage assessment so at the end
of the day iron eagle
has got to be the most ridiculous movie
about
fighter aviation that could have ever
been created i'm gonna stick with top
gun and i'm gonna stick with maverick at
the end of the day next up
dunkirk
so this is a uh believe it's a spitfire
so the battle of dunkirk just a
strategic
disaster in the military we have a term
called successful failure
the way that the british rallied to save
their troops from dunkirk
is just fantastic and the performance
out of these aviators was nothing less
than stellar
70 dollars
68 gallons fortis leader so obviously
back in the day
these guys aren't too worried about
oxygen mainly because they're not flying
really high up at altitude so they could
kind of have their mask hanging down
here and you can see how they
hold it up to their mouth to
realistically be able to talk
now they're checking out their fuel and
as you can see they're switching to
different tanks
so you know they can say hey the right
wing tank has this much or the
fuselage tank has this and the left wing
is that so they're reporting in with
their fuel state
and the reason you do this every once in
a while first of all what if all of a
sudden out of the blue you developed a
fuel leak and you didn't notice it
and all of a sudden you flame out so
checking your fuel periodically
you know keeps you keeps that scan going
even when it gets lively safe enough to
get back
so right now they're a little tight if
you're in bad guy country
you don't want to be flying close
formation as a bunch of airplanes
because if you look at the right wing
and the left wing those wingmen right
there are staring at who
they're staring at the flight lead right
now i don't want to be flying formation
in what we call sucking wingtip so these
two wingmen right now are sucking
wingtip
i want them spread out a little bit more
and their eyes out of the cockpit
looking around for enemy aircraft it
does no good to be flying
this close formation right now when you
could have
what six six eyeballs out of the sky
instead of just the flight lead looking
around
for this too i have you on my porch i
have no eyes on 40s either of it
understood for this one a little bit for
a look
so back in the day you know this early
on in dunkirk there wasn't any
aviation radar per se the the aircraft
just didn't have any radar the only
radar was your brain housing group
and your eyeballs so really having to
look hard out there
and and literally a speck on the horizon
could be an enemy fighter
all they had was their eyeball so they
were a lot better at picking up visual
and they had a much more disciplined
what we call scan meaning
they just didn't sit here and look
around randomly they had a pattern that
they would go through
and look through the sky and not
randomly so
where can you look for example this guy
on the right wing
can look behind the wing
that left wing means six o'clock right
and the left wingman
can look all the way to the right and
look behind
that guy's six o'clock so whenever you
hear the term
check six it means look behind you
flight discipline
and lookout discipline is very very key
in situations like this
and back in the day the best place and
even to today
in air and air combat you want to come
from what's called out of the sun
unless you're you know a superhuman you
can't stare into the sun
so if you come if you decide to attack
from out of the sun
you have a very big tactical advantage i
think we might actually see that
found it 11 o'clock
the first person who cites an enemy
aircraft you call it out
bandit and then the clock code bandit 11
o'clock
and you call out the position
he's on me so above
the canopy they actually had a mirror so
he he isn't straining to look behind him
at this point he's actually just looking
up above his canopy
into a mirror and he can see i believe
it's a
messerschmitt on his six o'clock
[Music]
[Applause]
so right now he's in a tough spot he's
got to shoot this german down but he
doesn't want to shoot his wingman down
[Music]
so there you go awesome so you're
looking at a gun reticle
so this is what is displayed right in
front of the pilot's vision it's right
in his line of sight
and in these old fighter planes the guns
out in the wings are aligned
to what we call right in the middle
right there that's called a pipper you
see that little orange dot that is right
on that dude's head
however when he's squeezing the trigger
right now guess where those bullets are
gonna go
behind him so what we have to do
whenever you're trying to shoot somebody
down
you have to do what we call pulling lead
so right now when he squeezes those
bullets there this guy's already going
to be gone from where he is right there
so he's got to aim
let's say i don't know one or two three
airplanes
in front of him to put those bullets out
in front of the bad guy so he flies
through them in a modern fighter
aircraft there's not that many i think
600 ish in the f-18 which might sound
like a lot
but it's literally this much you ready
that's it so about two to three seconds
if you kept the trigger down and the
f-18 you'd be out of bullets
a lot more back in the day these guys
weren't carrying air-to-air missiles or
radar so their wings were full of a lot
more ammunition once you're out of
bullets you're out of bullets i mean
there's been some circumstances of you
know guys running out of ammo and
ramming other airplanes
and we saw just horrifically in the
pacific for the japanese you used what
they called kamikaze
the divine wind they would lock these
guys in a plane like this
put a bunch of gas in a plane put a
bunch of bombs on it and have them go
try and crash
into an aircraft carrier or a ship they
were the first
if you want to call it guided bombs of
the modern warfare era
so even if you're running out of ammo
you still got you
at the end of the day
right there perfect shot and now he put
some rounds right in front of the german
aircraft and the german's gonna fly
right through boom
he's about to splash into the ocean so
splash one kind of navy fighter pilot
navy marine fighter pilot for i just
shot somebody down splash one
splash two splash three so great fighter
discipline
great pulling lead and didn't waste any
bullets
is he down
yeah he's down for the cat what happened
they're both staring where
had a dude flying into the water the guy
was on fire he's going into the water
why are they both staring at him and one
of them just got shot by who
another german so very very bad that's
the hair on the back your neck should
stand up if we're both staring at the
same piece of sky
or water in this case and nobody has
their eyes out looking
for the other bad guy so great scene
dunkirk great movie
and really speaks to the the heroism of
the uh of the men and women in the
royal air force you can tell that they
actually are using the spitfire aircraft
you can tell i think they even had the
actors in the airplanes uh so
very realistic all right thanks for
watching part two of the breakdown those
were some
awesome clips had an absolute blast make
sure you stay
safe out there and fly navy